chad cool pennsylvania lottery numbers
show you still looking for that w white
sox coming to town for a brief two-game
series starting tuesday night
a roller to second
well that's good work if chad cole's
been bothered by those baseballs he did
shake it off he threw out a couple out
of play and one two three
he uh he made his last uh his third
start on monday against baltimore did
not get the decision but he pitched well
hopefully he can get that pitch out over
the plate to do that
runner goes
ground ball third base they're gonna try
for oh the drop at second
so ramirez took a bit of a gamble
don't know whether frazier would have
been out
had the ball been caught
but everybody's safe
and a base hit reynolds looked like he
went down
to get that one and they are loaded
with bucks great piece of hitting by
brian reynolds again and staying down
keeping his head down right there two
strike hitting we talked about it all
the time great piece of hidden by brian
right there
3-2 and a swing of the ground ball up
first right at the bag bradley tags the
bag and gets that out only
frazier is in hayes to third
reynolds the second it's an rbi and the
pirates lead one nothing and now jacob
stallings and hits this ball toward
right center field the cheetah
he's going to get a couple
pirates are going to score two
on the double by jacob stallings three
nothing great job jacob using
old field right there again being
aggressive early in the count looking
for a ball out of the plate we talked
about it pregame
a big piece of hidden right there
gregory polanco to the plate
and there's a drive to right field
that's a tall cup of coffee
el cafe a two run homer
and it's five nothing
that's his seventh
nothing better than watching that sweet
swing when it's hot gregory polanco was
all over that fifth right there
that sinker's
thigh high out over the plate and
hitters count nothing better than
watching that ball sell into feeding
fans
[Applause]
look at that hit
[Applause]
oh double play whatever it was
that's what he asked for right there
that's what was needed within furniture
and mattress double play
sounded like it hit some
like metal on that one hit that
yeah
a little bit too
drive toward
left and that will do it
walk double play fly out good stuff and
chad cool and the pirates lead five
nothing
zimmer batting 255 with five ribbies
bounces one through the hole on the
shortstop side
last two years with the mets
this should be as easy as pie to get two
and they do
pirates turn double plays and
back-to-back innings behind chad cool
that's a beautiful thing again working
ahead of the count on the opposing
pitcher here's the pitch swinging a miss
laid on the fastball
inning ends chad cool has faced the
minimum
and a fly ball hit deep to right field
you can clear the deck with a cannonball
and anchor down
ryan reynolds number eleven and it's six
nothing pirates
[Applause]
target fire works early i like it
continue to swing in that hot bathroom
get that sinker again he's keeping that
sinker up in his own and then
pirates hit her that let him know
that there was some truth to what
cool was saying and there's a comebacker
oh how nice is that no wasted time i
think the guy in the radio booth next
door is probably
smiling bob walk that's a beautiful job
right there i mean again you know chad
cool's a pretty decent athlete doesn't
hesitate at all just gets the ball on
its way
and allows frazier to make the turn yeah
three and two
how about chad cool
six nothing
again it's almost like you forget when
you get to three two you gotta continue
to understand that two strike it back
there we go
that was a great job by chad right there
continuing to pound his own
it all started off with that and getting
me over breaking ball that he hadn't
nearly used it
he goes back to it right there
a diving stop by frazier on the first
what a play
out in shallow right
he can do it with a bat
and he does it with a glove
robbing naylor
nailing naylor at first
chad cool delivers there's a line
driving a single into center
on his way to third goes bradley zimmer
knee looks like it's just fine just
talking about uh playing
in the national league and the
adjustment there's a line drive hayes
throw to first base and another double
play that was a little unconventional
and thank you
renee rivera
absolutely it's a great job right there
dr brian hayes being able to secure it
out again and make sure he got a solid
throw over there across the column
around and it's just bad base running
right there again a snowboard
cesar with a base hit in the center
field and the indians are on the board
[Applause]
nelson firing and the pits swung on and
lifted in the air to shallow right
center and on the run diving naylor made
another great catch
[Applause]
josh naylor
has suddenly become a gold glover in
right field
he is leaving his feet almost on a daily
basis to make some kind of a spectacular
diving catch
base has loaded two outs jacob stallings
walked with one out
and then with two outs kevin newman
singled to left and kai tom just walked
to load them up 3-2 pitch
and
the pirates take a 7-1 lead third walk
of the inning give evans an rbi to bring
home stallings
oh
and that'll bring home another run
[Applause]
on an 02 pitch
fraser gets a ribby the hard way yeah i
think he got a breaking ball got away
from it went with the slider right there
catching at him right in that right
shoulder
some apparently are saying
this ball lined toward right field and
carries past naylor
key brian hayes is going to clean him up
that's a three-run double
that
just about puts it
in the hands of the pirates in the sixth
inning
can't say enough about brian hayes
ability to spray the ball all over the
ballpark and then hunt those rbis and i
know a lot of that that comes from the
dna charlie hayes was a rbi seeker
himself but
there's a hard hit ball in the hole
another run is in and everybody moves up
90.
eddie rosario's scoring
it's 11-3
and the payoff pitch
swung on hip pretty well to center
reynolds going back track whoa
a grand slam
to dead center
for cesar hernandez
the indians have scored six this inning
they trail 11-7
now the set now the pitch
hit him in the foot down goes ramirez
and he's in pain he is laying face down
in the dirt in the batter's box
as he got smoked
second indian to get hit tonight his
night is over man
now trailing 11 to seven here in the
eighth with the bases loaded two down
he swings and drills it to center base
hit here comes clement rosario right
behind him throw to third in sliding
safely zimmer ball carrums off shiver
into the pirate dugout simmers up to
score and rave renee rivera
has delivered and goes to third on the
throw into the dugout
it's a one-run game
11-10
the indians trail it
raise it
with a big fist bump
rich rod gets the save
ho-hum
10-game losing streak over
raise the jolly roger